[Music]
these School notebooks were to have
flown off the shelves next week when the
Greek school year begins they're
unusable now because they sat on the
lower shelves of this stationary shop in
the village of palamas which was flooded
down the street there's a stench of
spoiled meat from two butcher shops and
the local supermarket is throwing
everything out a quarter of a million
dollars worth of damage in this business
alone
police have come from all over the
country fearing an outbreak of
lawlessness but angry residents said
that's not the kind of state aid they
were looking for
three years was flooded and now it
happened in the surrounding Villages no
flood prevention had been done Millions
have been spent but on nothing
substantial we are living with climate
change now things are going to get worse
people need to be able to live work and
invest in their locality otherwise they
should tell us this area is
uninhabitable and we should leave
the government admitted it took three
years merely to assign an updated
National flood risk assessment that'll
take two more years to carry out
an opposition MP says it has dragged its
feet
we published the fast maps in 2018 with
the Sally and especially Volos are
painted red red meant danger instead of
dictating a plan to try and at least
limit Danger from flooding the
government ignored this this huge delay
is an admission of incompetence and
failure
there is anger against Authority here
when the head of the regional government
visited belamus this is what happened
people here are not only ruined they
have taken on much of the rescue they
feel abandoned and embracing themselves
for the death count
I've never cried but yesterday I cried
we saw people floating inside their
homes Through the Windows we didn't
count how many but we couldn't do
anything for them I believe we're going
to have a high death toll when the water
level drops we'll see the number of
bodies yesterday in kaskinas we saw the
claw marks on Windows of people who
tried to get out of their homes the
government says that the fire service
has rescued nearly 3 000 people and it
will start paying emergency compensation
of five thousand to eight and a half
thousand dollars on Monday but it has
kept silent on the number of missing and
drowned and some people here don't
believe that the full death toll will
ever be made public in the meantime
local volunteers are still doing
everything they can to keep that death
toll from rising further
Al Jazeera in the village of palamas in
Central Greece
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera